uh-uh bad news for Donald Trump there
are now more people in the United States
who want Donald Trump impeached than the
number that approve of the job he is
doing this is not good for Donald Trump
we've been tracking Trump's approval
rating and it's back down near its
presidency lows the Gallup daily
tracking poll bottomed out at 35 percent
on March 28th it's sort of popped back
up a bit into the low 40s back down to
36 percent yesterday 37 percent today so
there's a 3 percent margin of error
basically Trump's approval rating is
equal to as low as it's been for his
entire presidency thus far compare that
the 37 percent approval rating to the
latest political morning consult poll
which shows that 43% of Americans now
support starting impeachment proceedings
against Donald Trump does this matter
well it does in a couple of senses one
is what we can expect from Trump this
week especially considering the upcoming
testimony of fired FBI director James
Comey on Thursday tweets to distract
tweets to distort tweets to preempt and
it already started this morning tweets
like for example from Donald Trump
the fake mainstream media is working so
hard to get me to not use social media
they hate that I can get the honest and
unfiltered message out the funniest line
from the write-ups about the approval
numbers is the following which is from a
Newsweek article about this quote
whereas Trump enjoyed record high
popularity near the end of his first
trip abroad since assuming the Oval
Office
nearing 42% or above in several polls or
indexes now he is once again in the
historic territory of being one of the
least popular new presidents in modern
American history how poorly are things
going Pat when 42% represents your
record high approval it's possible that
some of the Trump supporters just think
we're winning too much underneath that's
why they supported impeachment yeah 42%
is both it's hilarious that that's as
high as he got and it's shocking that he
actually got that high as well given
that he's accomplished nothing the
reality is as Pat's alluding to the
committed trumpets are committed quite
literally they will never criticize
per say they disapprove no matter what
he does they already believe that he is
a great savior president they believed
many of them anyway that for the last
eight years
President Obama was the worst president
in American history where it matters for
the u.s. today is not that low
information trumpets think Trump is a
hero
it matters that the world opinion of the
US goodwill and willingness to work with
us was higher under President Obama than
it had been for a long time recall the
opinion of the world about us under
george w bush disaster and donald trump
is single-handedly destroyed most of
that goodwill in just four months that's
actually a major accomplishment of the
trump administration in terms of its
scope it's a disaster but it's actually
an amazing accomplishment how quickly
donald trump has destroyed the image of
the united states around the world in
such a short period of time